Volodymyr Zelensky came into power in April 2019...
...with no political or military experience.
The 44-year-old was previously only known for his acting career.
The Ukrainian president now finds himself on the frontline...
...of the most serious crisis in Europe since the Cold War.
Our boys and girls, all defenders of Ukraine,...
...did not allow the enemy...
...to implement the operational plan of invasion on the first day.
Ukrainians showed real heroism.
The enemy was stopped in most directions.
He now faces a formidable Russian force...
...as President Vladimir Putin claims...
...he is attempting to demilitarize and denazify Ukraine.
Experts have claimed Putin's objective is to topple the regime in Kiev.
The Ukrainian leader says his fate lies in the balance.
Zelensky has appealed for help from NATO,...
...but so far, he has only received military equipment and financial aid.